welcome back gamers Sunnah the mr. beast
gaming video the premise is simple we
have a volcano we have a hundred random
people here's how it's gonna work
there's a switch right here that opens
this box and lets them roam around the
map Carl is competing hello it's me me
and Chris will be dropping items bla bla
bla flick the switch and they're off to
the race whoever is the last man
standing wins $10,000 now we have PvP
turned off for the moment but in a
second I'm gonna allow them to hit each
other okay
lovers are help or turn on PvP for 10
seconds Oh PvP zone they found out they
found out PvP is on for the next 5
seconds 4 3 2 1 alright cut it off the
week have been weeded out I'm watching
this guy die
you got over here man figure it out
there's actually nerve wracking you know
what else is nerve wrecking about this
Carl oh there's a creeper right beside
you did you kill Carl I think you've got
alright well I didn't think you they're
all shaking their head at me
Carl I'm sorry I didn't know that it
would blow you up you gotta just hit it
into the lava I didn't know the creeper
would blow you up yeah
I didn't know you were that bad that you
didn't know how to PvP a creeper off
move out the way the speaker doctor no
oh alright
boom Oh Oh somebody would don't kill him
God knows does mean I didn't mean to I
put the creeper down you put him down
after I blew him up she was in the air
yeah and then you put it down right
where she landed alright Chris is on the
rampage over here
no kidding Jimmy alright PvP is on boys
pay attention
thanks gang up out of here's our oh look
they're ganging up on him I didn't tell
him but they're fighting for 10 grand
they don't even realize it but Nana Oh
banana vendor one daddy's so muddy wait
wait Oh Chandler you're back where'd you
go no message it mmm all right
challenges you know ten grands online
it's a pee-pee people hey no arena never
you get the point
you look for ten grand let's go yeah
these cats are serving my kids - they're
gonna push you off and let the cat pee
in a bucket Chandler ah no my cats yeah
do these pillagers they snipe people
watch this Oh today really it's not Oh
simp please I love how he's just
dominating spawn Island are you not
entertained
[Music]
abandon ship dog he refuses to leave
Jimmy I'm making a sniper on a nest
Jimmy I found a friend look Oh soup Oh
sniper tower oh my gosh it's so funny
Chandler what's your friend's name
Bogdan say hey Barr good I'll just talk
but I'll give you a sword if you kill
him right now Jan no trust each other
that was my test to see if you're a good
friend
you failed why are there so many cats
everywhere their inbox will do it I'm
not living this world if I'm a bad
friend we need you for content what are
you dr. Taylor why did you run the
instant ITV's you told me okay all right
I'm gonna connect this person to the
other two the world cat oh oh oh that
was ruthless
that was robot men is ruthless fight it
out Duke it out he's running he's scared
Oh
for that duel you've earned yourself a
present oh oh not in it oh oh they tried
to invade Skyfire oh my god I got to
give him that that's my gift to him can
these creepers explode the Rhino over
I'm sorry the other one survived dude
everyone's terrified a robot man cuz
here's the show I'm gonna slowly break
robot men's platform
this guy's given bullied by three magma
cubes oh my God look at him he's trying
to fight him off
get out of here robot man get out of
here robot man oh now alright robot man
fight fight to the death
oh yes robots in a war but he has a
sword will he win oh oh oh
kill two of them how about the third the
final oh oh he's going off oh this guy's
a freaking warrior robot man is gonna go
on a conquest until he dies Go Go oh oh
where did she come from
what wow dude she really jumped over
here to get that she deserved that
alright is she fighting let's see oh
she's taking him on but sushi wins
oh she killed one Oh oh my gosh Wow oh
my god she's heartless oh oh my gosh oh
no that's the one you gave the boat oh
oh they're fighting how's the Friday
face face Oh zero to kill him oh he's
got a hint of pearl he just always did
what whirling he's gonna lose oh let's
see who wins
oh she got
Oh Jase hon hon hon hood go go go go get
the kill oh all right let's see you'll
see all right
thousand ten he's back no I'm gonna pray
to her she's so good
Kris what are you gonna do if she dies
I'm gonna be sad zero to K it died
she'll turn into a mech and live on
forever hey look at our go-kart cos I am
this man down guys boy Jedi's back and
he has a teammate this time there's the
Argo is waiting for it there's only
Tigger yeah they only do one end of the
Nerds lives on Argo is gonna be ruthless
are we great guys store guys without a
sword okay
oh he ran away or go oh my gosh banana
thunder banana fritter go up go up all
zero twos gonna go out here 200 zero
back Oh zero to acting like a helpless
huge anime girl mm-hmm little does he
know she has weapons kill her I bet she
backstab some how about this let me do
this I bet they go to war oh that was so
adorable
alright I'm dropping a sword right here
I bet I bet everyone rushes for it Argos
ready to dart goes waiting
sword down oh oh oh my god Oh Oh all
right there fighting whose side is
banana gonna help dude she's she's out
for blood here's some more arrows there
you go oh there's a fight on the Eastern
quadrant oh oh boy Jedi oh no poor Jedi
no no Jenny do banana flowers still here
a 0-200 your girl's under attack you're
gonna double-team my girl Oh
no he did this guy looks like he wants
to join in the fight here you go give me
that give me it banana and apple pie are
together right now they are teammate
alright I feel like a Wars about to
break over here in the northeastern
mmm-hmm I've kind of grown a liking to
Argo I feel like we've given the enemy
girl too much love she's getting it so I
typed in the chat I was about to drop a
diamond chestplate here and I'm seeing
if I can lure people in yes she said she
put on the armor oh wait oh banana got
it banana got it and recovered oh my god
Apple got it we talked about Jedi every
video and it's because he won this one
he already won $10,000 like a week and a
half ago
alright here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna start canceling certain quadrants
all dude this guy was hiding in a corner
the entire time here Oh
fight going on boy Jedi vs Apple wait
wait Charlie move away from him ooh jeez
who's getting all the who's getting
milk-bones
Oh banana it's banana gonna get it all
they're going for it they're going for
it
oh oh oh bananas gonna ward all right
this is it this gets decide who gets the
10 grand banana
by God
remaining we have we have squiddy you
have Anat we had the duo we have Donald
Duck then we have this guy on Cat Island
there you go oh oh banana is not
settling bananas being ruthless here's a
bow fire we hit him all right he's going
in he's going in we're about to have a
mainland fight oh he's trying he's
trying to have peace oh they just needs
he ruthlessly murdered him
he was trying to team lava is gonna move
them all out and they are now gonna
compete for $10,000 all right they're
getting close all right here we go block
everything else off except for these
islands over here all right so it
appears we have two teams $10,000 is on
the line
Donnell wants it Donald what's it
oh dude they like they have their bows
drawn they're trying to scare people off
they're so angry like they're like get
away I'm gonna cut off
Donald's old Island sorry Donald it is
now a thing of the past go for boys Duke
it out okay okay I've got it
nobody's fainted oh oh dude Donald Joey
go look Donald's like Hank
Donald all right I like this oh my gosh
all right these 3v2
quod number 1 has been eliminated
alright Oh are they gonna team up on
dominoed versus the world right now
diode will not calm down he is an animal
guys donal needs boots if it's to be won
Donald deserves so he deserves some
diamond boots don't let him leave you
don't let him leave Amit and squid I'm
sorry but only one of you can win 10
grand so you got this far but you guys
got a Duke it out
I'm sorry three two one fight Amit are
you still in the call yeah yeah yeah
Squidward wanted to split the $10,000
with you and give you five grand if he
hears you right now if I had the option
I want to say to God to place you with
like 110 thousand places subscribe to
vista beast
thank you so much thomas the beasts mr.
beast gaming we'll see you in the next
video